all right so the peripheral has now come
to a close giving us a strange trippy
parallel timeline sci-fi real doll
future fest with one of the Westworld
creators attached you know it was gonna
get heady but in this video we're going
to be discussing the ins and outs of the
ending of this series what is up with
all of those bees are predictions for
what a potential season 2 might have in
store along with our general thoughts of
this series as a whole but thank you for
clicking this video I'm your sim jockey
Jared so saddle up and let's get into
the ending of the peripheral
[Music]
now as a brief outline of what the heck
is going on in the peripheral
um here we go so Flynn lives in 2032
North Carolina with her brother Burton
who is ex-military both taking care of
their sick mother backwoods town nothing
to do it's tough to make money because
you know uh everyone in the town is kind
of in the pocket of one Corbin Pickett
your run-of-the-mill small town bad guy
who runs it all anyway to make money
Burton is a Sim jockey ushering Rich
folk through VR think Ready Player one
but uh you know you know what a ready
ready player one is actually a great
comparison however Flynn is way better
at the Sim than Burton she is an
Explorer type trying to break the game
learning the ins and outs as she goes
welp they get roped into a huge score of
a job assassinations weird robots
seduction ripping out eyeballs and a
heist of some state-of-the-art
technology mumbo jumbo but here is the
kicker are you are you ready are you
sitting down are you ready for this the
Sim that they are playing is actually
the real world London set in 2099 what
in the quantum tunneling time travel
Great Scott is this so with this being
realized combined with the fact that
real people were killed and something
was actually stolen all sorts of
scrambles kick off people from the
future try to eliminate the pair in the
past with Sonic Blast weapons and
invisible cars Paperboy man this is like
Atlanta but Flynn gains Intel from the
future to not only find Elita West the
missing person from the original Sim but
to help her in her present time and
learns of something called the jackpot
oh man that sounds great a ton of money
you know the oh oh it's called the
jackpot oh wow okay it's called the
jackpot because a handful of apocalyptic
a disasters pile on top of one another
like winning the jackpot at least the
Futures optimistic all of this
essentially comes to a head when Flynn
is targeted by the ri or rather the
research institute and the head of IT Dr
Cherise Newland aka the queen bee
cherries wants Flynn dead while trying
to accelerate the jackpot in her time
while Flynn is trying to understand why
she wants her dead and exposing the ri
with the immoral technology that they
possess and what they are going to be
doing with it and what they have been
doing with it now the ending sees Elita
finally revealing herself still alive
and in removing her immunity booster she
starts remembering the ri Tech that is
supposed to quote help them has a bit of
a side effect manipulating their
memories when her and wolf were children
that clept including Lev's father were
terrified of a supposed contagion in
relief camps there by the way there is
no proof of this at all and slaughtered
roughly 5 million people in a fortnight
another reason why there are little to
no people living in London elitist plan
this whole time is to expose the ri for
covering this up using the infinity in
the palm of their hand technology which
is the bacterial DNA in Flynn's skull in
doing so societal trust in both the
klept and RI will dwindle reverting back
to how Humanity used to live relying you
know a little bit less on the
breakthroughs of The Institute however
Elita needs Flynn basically everyone is
after Flynn now because of what she has
in her head and the only person that can
be trusted is inspector lobeer severing
her stub from the future is
unfortunately out of the cards but
lobeer says that she can open up a new
stub highly unethical but it is possible
through one of the ri's quote stub
portals a pretty generic name don't you
think Flynn makes her way towards a
hidden stub portal which is located
right outside of a cemetery which seems
fitting for all of the deaths that were
overlooked without second thought by the
ri Flynn grabs the stub portal key which
is in the form of a golden pocket watch
dispatches some prips and slams The
Watch into place essentially in theory
allowing her to jump and create a new
stub a quote reboot for her Sim because
where she is at right now is a black
hole there is no progressing forward
from there I had this happen in Resident
Evil 4 and I was not happy anyway Flynn
opens the stub but in doing so destroys
the pocket watch so the ri and Cherise
cannot track her they haven't a clue
what stub she's going back to they can
only guess which is a cheeky nod to the
episode's title the creation of a
thousand forests trees branches stubs
you get it back in the main stub Flynn
tells Connor to shoot her I am not
shooting a kid yeah it seemed seems
pretty crazy but this is the stuff that
everyone has been monitoring and she
must end it and in turn create a new
branching path Flynn counts down from 10
remembering memories that soon may not
be the ones that she remembers and Conor
gets closure for the puppy instant from
earlier and shoots Flynn dead you shot
me I'm dead this is supposed to make it
look like low beer sent out a hit for
her and it was successful allowing
Charisse off her back no longer asking
questions about Flynn any further
believe me there is a lot of sci-fi
mumbo jumbo Paradox stuff going through
your brain right now but the Flynn we
know is gone but a different one in a
different stub unknown from everyone
except inspector lobeer is now the one
to move forward with ending the ri
elitist Revolution and the klept all
with the help of low beer as the two get
to work symbolically this self-sacrifice
for a replacement of Flynn's self was
actually hinted of the two groom Toppers
back in episode one two identical one
snapped in half ending its Journey while
the other moves on now you might have
missed this but surprisingly there is a
post-credit stinger after the credits of
episode 8. this features Lev and
Dominica zubove both going off to some
ritzy club for lunch only for Lev to be
greeted by three older gentlemen
grilling him about his dealings with the
ri these are leading individuals of the
cleped and Friends of Lev's father they
aren't too fond of Lev trying to recruit
someone from the ri this is in reference
to Cherise and her Associates and that
he should tie up any Loose Ends AKA
prune the branches in regards to the
stubs so it looks like Lev needs to deal
with cherries in some fashion maybe even
pulling another Yuri samsonov
eliminating her from all of the stubs
but this is going to cause a multitude
of problems because the three wall
structure will cause everything to
crumble inward but Cherise has Lev's DNA
from the teacup in episode 4 I believe
so any sense of wrongdoing that she
maybe feels will preemptively be planned
on the part of Therese and the ri plus
if Lev does go through with this does
this start another jackpot we'll talk
more about that in the rest of the video
but if you're looking for a jockey then
please hit that thumbs up button and
make sure to subscribe to join the
spoiler Sim because we're dropping some
heavy breakdowns oh shoot uh Paul's
calling gotta go but yeah hit the button
okay before we get into our season two
theories we gotta talk about the bees
yes we have to because they are
everywhere mentioned symbols held even
Flynn is dressed as one in her Halloween
Home Video in almost every single
episode there is something relating to
bees episode 1 features Burton's
sporting a B on his bandana cherries
there is also said to be the queen bee
at the party the hexagons of the decor
resemble honeycomb and the metcoids you
know the like the cool looking robot
dudes well their faces have kind of a
similar structure episode 2 features
bees on the television stating that each
individual B has a significant role to
play in serving the larger needs of the
colony they all contribute to the
healthy functioning of the hive none can
survive without the help of the others
however
environmental pressures have caused
their population to Free Fall hinting
and hint at the jackpot again episode 3
has cherries using bees as a form of
entomological warfare I if you could
call it that I guess with the beehives
being also hexagonal shaped the same
design being on cherise's dress and the
teacup even a clever transition to a bug
zapper after the scene referencing that
the queen bee has got to go episode 4 is
the Halloween home video with Lynn
dressed as a little bumblebee along with
one of the environmental catastrophes of
the jackpot being the extinction of bees
which in turn has a ripple effect and
episode 7 has inspector low beer
referring to the Met police algorithm as
the aunties the Mets data sorting
algorithms busy Little Bees buzzing
about but why the bees sure they are all
there but why are they in this show well
a couple different reasons again
referencing episode 2 the narrator on
the television mentions workers the
drones the queen they all contribute to
the healthy functioning of the hive and
none of them not even the queen herself
can survive without supporting the
others this three-party Cooperative
structure can be likened to cherise's
three-wall house analogy back in episode
4 whereas the queen drones and workers
are in theory the same as the klept Met
police and the research institute not
identically matching how these bees
function but the klept oligarchy used
extreme violence and was able to bring
order from the chaos of the jackpot
though on the scummy side of things they
run in open hand and Blind Eye mentality
the Met police keep the klept from
strain too far from certain boundaries
allowing their activities to persist and
the research Church Institute benefits
from the peace and prosperity that
results and provides technical
assistance for the society to function
and Thrive all working together despite
differences for the betterment of the
hive or you know Society but
unfortunately it is all a very very
fragile structure at any moment the roof
or you know the three walled house top
the top of the house you don't have a
house with three walls is what I'm
saying could come crashing down if
something Strays resulting in
essentially the end of the world much
like our current day ecosystems one tiny
shift could result in our own jackpot
one of which scientists have kind of
been talking about is the extinction of
bees one small Ripple that gets bigger
and bigger as the waves go outward it is
interesting because cherries believes in
this structuring but also in the
complete opposite Camp when saying that
the bees are ignorant not having a clue
how vulnerable they are while she and
the ri had to prevent two extinction
level events interjecting that human or
rather her intervening is the key to
their survival and that population
filled back in after the long climb back
up from nothingness in a grander sense
the ri building Humanity back up after
the jackpot potentially utilizing you
know graphene which we're not going to
get into that but molecularly they do
have a hexagonal structure AKA honeycomb
shaped going back to the bees it's all
connected man a great example of how
fragile everything is is the case with
the meddling of Flynn that could be this
tiny tiny little thing years and years
in the past that could have a huge
ripple effect Hell she's even dressed as
a bee at one point it could be positive
or negative but with the information she
possesses from the ri in a roundabout
way nothing kind of exists without her
this is why cherries is doing anything
in her power to stop Flynn on whatever
path she is on and accelerate the
jackpot look at Flint from every angle
because what effects does she change in
2099 society and human history in the
next what 70 years cherries doesn't lose
her place at the table the the power she
has the position and time she finds
herself sure stubs prevent any sort of
paradox but all of this could change
with one little tiny
[ __ ]
as for where season two could go it'll
definitely lean into the weird sci-fi
elements a bit more because the Flynn
and present that we know is no longer
going to be the Flynn and present we
know you know basically her surviving at
the end is low beer using a different
stub to bring her into the fold so these
two will be working together to expose
the ri in some fashion without the three
walls crumbling down even though things
are a bit shaky because elita's little
Revolution which was hinted all the way
back at the start of the series however
with things driving into a different
stub I'm curious how this will affect
what we've actually seen and in doing so
will we see all of these events play out
again but in dramatically different ways
because the past has a lot of fork in
the road moments for characters other
than Flynn Tommy has a lot of tough
decisions to make in episode 7 Jasper
taking the money from Corbin and also
the phone call with his wife at the
railroad tracks Bob in the hospital
thinking about who should die and Conor
rescuing the dog or not it could be an
interesting Wizard of Oz Journey but
also discount what has happened so far
now one huge Theory I have is that Lev
zubov or the one that we've seen is
actually a peripheral this skin walker
ain't fooling anyone and it's because of
all of these kind of small hints first
off rich and powerful people tend to use
peripherals as a safe safety precaution
which we see cherries use but also that
Flynn found evidence of the zubo family
dying in a mafia hit in her time back in
2032. sure the mafia hit was part of Lev
you know killing all of himself in these
different stubs straight up gently in
the one style but this would make him
roughly a hundred-ish years old sure
chalk it up as some anti-aging drugs
maybe it's Maybelline but London didn't
start rebuilding until the 70s so I'm
convinced Lev and the other members of
the klept including his father are on
life support somewhere else but piloting
these peripherals like they are youthful
again we could go one deeper and someone
else could even be piloting Lev's
peripheral hell what if it's actually
Yuri samsonov
wait a minute yeah he didn't actually
get wiped out there was one of him left
he wiped out all of Lev and his family
and then took over I mean a clept would
do that I also think a majority of the
people walking around London are
actually peripherals being piloted by
essentially people or brains in tubes in
the lower levels of the ri we saw the ri
having floors and floors of technology
and this would allow for the rich to
essentially live forever this could even
explain the zuboves but the ri is using
the technology to gain information to
essentially evolve the next generation
of robot human hybrids because if we
remember Beatrice essentially the task
master of this show seriously she's even
watching game tape of the fights and
everything but she reveals she would
pick Connor rather than Burton after the
fighting exercise despite Burton being
the better more logical pick this tells
me that she has feelings compassion
something deep down she can't explain
towards him something AI shouldn't but
is involving into
I I I I don't know man it sounds pretty
crazy to me
I kinda dug the first season of the
peripheral I mean the Sci-Fi elements
really drew me in during the first
couple of episodes slowly introducing
these new characters technology the
robots the the robot dudes were pretty
cool and honestly a lot of questions I
kept asking now wait wait how does this
not change the future if Flynn does X
but the story is right there to explain
those questions in a logical and
meaningful way does it get a bit sci-fi
heady with all of the names like poulton
metcoid and klept yeah absolutely I'm
like what the hell is going on with this
what does any of this mean you know I
don't speak Spanish luckily though I
watched everything with subtitles so
we're all good I'd say the biggest thing
that interrupted the VR dream of this
series was the last couple of episodes
it was leading to this Grand reveal of
Elita and wilf and Lev all budding heads
with cherries and low beer but it felt
rushed into an ending of find out next
week on the peripheral sure it's ripe
for theories but it seemed too fast with
little explanation of how or why also
the top tier periphs that were guarding
the ri stub portal went out like some
major Chumps I'd probably give this
season a 7 out of 10 as of now maybe a
re-watch might make things a little bit
clearer better seamless rushed but I
really enjoyed Jack Reiner and Chloe
Grace Moretz I mean I wouldn't mind
getting a peripheral you know what never
mind I'm not gonna say it but obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on season
one of the peripheral did this scratch
that sci-fi itch and where do you think
a potential season 2 might go and I'll
let you know we're currently running a
competition right now giving away three
copies of House of dragons season one on
the 15th of December and all you gotta
do to get a chance of winning this is
like this video subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment Down
Below on the peripheral we picked the
comments at random at the end of every
single month and last month winners are
on screen right now so if that's you
message us on Twitter at heavy spoilers
if you want something else to watch be
sure to check out some of our other cool
videos this week has been packed full of
trailer breakdowns so treat yourself
with that out of the way thank you for
watching this I've been Jared and I'm
gonna pull it over to jalio London and
get some tea and scrumpets Tip Top
Cheerio all right uh I'll I'll see in
the next one